this next question is I mean I'm taking
it as a real question but it is also I
can set tell someone who just doesn't
understand what the hell is going on in
the United States the question is hey
Americans and David what the f is wrong
with you I live in the UK and I see you
vote in this idiot Trump are you people
this stupid he's obviously a criminal
every which way and you can't remove him
and Republicans don't want to seriously
what is wrong with your country the
world is laughing you know this is
interesting for a few reasons
it's interesting number one because
there are a lot of Trumpets who when
they see that attitude from someone in
the UK about what we're doing here about
Trump being president they're emboldened
in some way they see that and they say
oh these stupid [ __ ] Europeans don't
like what Trump is doing it's because
he's doing what's good for America he's
making America great again
who cares if they don't like what
Trump's doing it's good some even
believe that they don't like what
Trump's doing because it's not good for
them it's good for us and unfortunately
those are not people that can be
reasoned with and I share this sympathy
I share these sentiments I sympathize
with this perspective when I travel to
Europe and talk to my friends or family
in the UK or in France or when I talk to
my cousins in Israel who are not
right-wingers or when I talk to my
family in Argentina or friends in Italy
for example in Canada nobody really
understands what's going on they're
number one
feeling that they come to me with is
explain not just how this happened
because okay we can sort of understand
there was like a racist reaction to
Obama
there was dislike of Hillary there was
Trump bamboozling people into them
thinking that he is that the outsider
guy who's gonna you know who economic
anxiety preying on people's fear of
losing status or perceived status they
get all that but it's been two and a
half years now it's been two and a half
years how is everybody not against the
sky and what you need to understand is
everybody will never be against the sky
and I don't know if it's 20 25 28 ish
percent of the voting public that is
never ever ever going to abandon the sky
they will never be convinced to say you
know what I was wrong some people have
been convinced in that way I've taken
phone calls from some of those people
but there's this hardcore base that will
never be convinced so my answer to you
is that this is a combination of
hyper-partisanship
but that's too benign and that doesn't
include any kind of culpability in it
okay it's hyper partisanship it's
cognitive dissonance
it is also to use your term it is
stupidity in the sense that a lot of
people just lack information they are in
their echo chamber filter bubble they
never hear about half of what's going on
and when they do they have been primed
to write it off as fake news so we are
in trouble I know the world is laughing
I don't like that the world is laughing
and it actually hurts us that the world
is laughing but if you're waiting for
that hardcore base of 20 22 25 28
percent whatever the number is to come
to their senses don't hold your breath
because you're gonna you're gonna end up
without oxygen to breathe quite frankly